Opera, that's a good one.
That's good. It was opera,
yes. What opera? No, it wasn't
Wagner, but that's a good guess.
It's certainly a reasonable style,
way over the top. That was Maria
Callas singing La Mamma Morta from
Andrea Chenier,
which was written in 1895,
and premiered in the spring of 1896
exactly at the time when the world
was going nuts over this mysterious
form of radiation that can see
inside the human body.
So, I thought that was a good match.
The thing's best in class. That's
Maria Callas. This is opera for
those of you who don't like opera.
This, by the way, some of you may
recognize if you saw the movie
Philadelphia. This is the piece
that's playing when the Tom Hanks
character visits the loft,
or excuse me, the Denzel Washington
character visits the loft of the Tom
Hanks character.
And this is playing.
It's a fantastic piece,
way over the top. And this is Maria
Callas who is the woman that
restored melodrama to opera.
It's fantastic. So go and listen
to it. Enjoy it.
And, there's Bertha Roentgen's hand,
reminding us of the fact that you
always irradiate the one
you love. [LAUGHTER]
All right, so I have a few
announcements.
Next week, a week from today,
there will be no lecture, instead,
celebration of learning.
Celebration number two,
Wednesday the 27th, coverage through
today's lecture.
We'll go through the generation of
x-rays but we won't touch anything
to do with the use of x-rays and
indexing crystals,
Bragg's law, any of that stuff.
So, anything we talk about today I
think is fair game.
And, we'll go back to the early part.
So, I think last time we said up
until the 22nd.
So, I'm going to say the 22nd is
fair game. We started talking about
the properties of ionic compounds
and electron transfer,
octet stability. So, we'll go
through all of these.
We've covered a fair bit of ground,
and will end with x-ray spectra, but
not Bragg's Law.
OK, second thing I want to remind
people that I had a staff meeting
yesterday, and many of my recitation
instructors said that some of you
are puzzled to learn that there's
more than one book,
that the text is, in fact,
three volumes.
And right now,
the x-ray readings are coming from
this volume here called the course
supplement. So,
you need to be aware of that,
and also some of the best material
is in the archive notes on the Web,
and also all of these images that I
show, they get posted as well.
So, some of you are feverishly
taking notes. And that's good,
but if you miss something, you can
go and take it off the
website as well.
Last point that came out of the
staff meeting last night,
a number of people are becoming
tardy about taking the weekly
quizzes. You are allowed to miss
the weekly quiz for either health
reasons or some crisis in the family,
but not because she just decided to
sleep in or you decided you'd like
to take it at a later time.
So, I'm giving the TAs discretion
to deny you the right to take a make
up unless it's proper.
I'm not asking that you come with a
medical certificate or anything;
we'll take you on your honor.
But I do expect you to take those
tests when they're offered.
If you can't, take it on the day,
you can take a makeup up to one week.
After that, we want to close the
books on it. And,
we're not going to allow you,
as is the practice in other classes,
to throw away your bottom two or
three scores. If you don't take
them, you'll get zeros,
and that gets averaged in to your
homework grade.
I want you to have the discipline
of weekly homework and weekly
homework quizzes.
So, I know that recitation
instructors are announcing this,
but I want you all to hear it from
me as well. It's good for your
mental health to take those tests,
you know? It keeps you sharp. So,
last day we talked about Roentgen
and the discovery of x-rays.
Roentgen was working in this
laboratory studying gas discharge
tubes. And, his special take was
high-voltage and low pressure.
And, under these circumstances,
he was generating, unbeknownst to
him until the night of November 8,
1895, photons of wavelength
approximately one angstrom.
And, we looked at the relevant
physics and concluded that we could
explain the generation of x-rays by
this energy level diagram,
which is the energy level diagram of
the target.
This is the anode.
Remember the gas discharge tube has
a cathode, which is charged
negatively? And,
electrons are made to boil off the
cathode, accelerate from rest,
and they crash into the anode over
here. And, we think when these
electrons crash into the anode,
they cause a set of operations that
ultimately result in the admission
of photons in the x region
of the spectrum.
So, this is the energy levels of the
element here in the target.
And, we reasoned that these
incident electrons coming with
kinetic energy imparted by
acceleration voltages in the range
of tens of thousands of volts have
enough energy to come in and
actually dislodge inner shell
electrons. And,
in the extreme, N equals one,
K shell electrons.
And when that happens,
there's vacancies that invite a
cascade. So, we have a cascade of
electrons in the anode target from
higher levels down to lower levels.
And, as you know, going back to the
early part of 3.
91 when electrons move from
high-energy to low energy,
photons are emitted. And these
photons are the source of the x-rays.
These are the x-rays here.
So, we saw that if we had a vacancy
in the k shell,
we could get electrons moving from L
shell down to K shell.
And, such a photon was termed a K
alpha photon, K because the photon
came from an electron cascade into
the K shell, alpha because it came
from one shell above K.
There's a slight chance that the
electron may fall from N equals
three down to N equals one.
That's a greater energy difference.
And, we will get a K photon, but K
beta, K beta indicating that the
photon fell to K from two levels up.
And, even just to complete the
picture, I put K gamma.
Well, if there is vacancies in the
K shell, if we have enough energy to
dislodge electrons from K shell,
we certainly have enough energy to
dislodge electrons from L shell.
Vacancy here would invite a cascade
from N equals three to N equals two.
This would be L alpha because L is
the destination shell,
alpha meaning you came from one
shell above. And,
in the event that you fall from two
shells above, N equals four
down to N equals two.
This will be an L beta photon,
and thus was the way we left it last
day. And, the last thing was that
the instant energy values here,
and therefore, the instant
wavelengths are determined by the
chemical identity of the target.
If I change the composition of the
target, I have a different internal
energy structure,
and I'll get a different set of
emissions.
So, that's what was left at the end
of last day. So,
now the question is,
is there a quantitative relationship
between any of this,
specifically, is there a
quantitative relationship between
the chemical identity of the target
and any of these wavelengths that
are observed? And the answer is yes.
And for that,
we go back to Manchester and the
person of a young graduate student
at the name of Henry Moseley.
He was a graduate student working
under Rutherford in 1913,
1914. And, he was conducting a
study, what we call a systematic
study. For those of you who intend
to become graduate students,
I want to let you know this is a
very dangerous word.
What systematic means,
it's polite talk for tons and tons
of measurements,
systematic. His systematic study
was to take the x-ray generator and
change the chemical identity
of the target.
And, he conducted a study of no
fewer than 38 elements,
systematically changing the chemical
identity of the target,
and measuring the spectrum,
the emission spectrum for 38
elements. He started as low as
aluminum and went all the way up to
gold, stopping 38 places
along the way.
And, he measured the wavelengths of
these x-rays, and he found a pattern.
What he found was that as the
molecular weight or as the atomics,
and we are just dealing with
elements, as the atomic weight rose,
the wavelengths fell. So, I'm
comparing apples and apples.
So, let's compare all of the K
alpha lines. So,
the lambda, K alpha,
would fall as the heavier and
heavier elements were used.
And, here is the plate from one of
his papers. This is a beautiful
piece of work.
These are the photographic plates
along the lines of the Balmer series,
only this is from the x region of
the spectrum. So,
here's calcium, titanium,
vanadium, chromium, manganese,
iron, cobalt, nickel, copper, and
brass.
Here's where he's going.
There's calcium; didn't have
scandium. It was too rare,
and still to this day, very,
very expensive. So, now he's moving
across the transition metals.
He gets to copper, and he can't use
zinc for reasons I'm going to show
you very shortly,
namely that the energy in that tube
is so high that he's going to melt
the zinc. So,
he says instead I'll use brass which
is an alloy of copper and zinc.
And, so this is the data from his
study. And, so here's the first
page of the paper.
"The author intends to make a
general survey of the principal
types of high-frequency radiation,
examine the spectra of the few
elements in greater detail.
The results already obtained show
that such data have an important
bearing of the question on the
internal structure of the atom and
further support the views of
Rutherford and of Bohr.
This is what he's putting up here
for us. And, what I want to show is
that when he took his results this
is what he found.
He tried to get a better
functionality of this relationship
between wavelengths and atomic
weights. And here's what he found
worked best. He found that if he
plotted not the wavelength but the
wave number, which we've seen before,
the wave number as a function
of proton number.
And, in fact, the square of the
proton number he got a linear
relationship. So,
and let's just say this would be L
alpha, L beta,
K alpha, K beta.
Let's say you are at copper.
So, copper would be 29 squared.
So, he would get data for the L
alpha line of copper,
the L beta line of copper,
K alpha line of copper, K beta line
of copper.
He might not get all four lines for
every element,
that he would take sets of data and
plot them out.
And he found that if he plotted the
reciprocal of the wavelength versus
the square of the proton number,
the points lay on a line. So, over
here would be aluminum,
and over here would be gold.
And, this was extremely important.
This changed so much because look
at what he's able to conclude here.
Let's read his paper here.
"We have here a proof that there is
in the atom a fundamental quantity
which increases by regular steps as
we pass from one element to the next.
This quantity can only be the
charge on the central positive
nucleus of the existence of which we
have already definite proof.
And, remember, when Mendeleev
enunciated the law of periodicity,
he said that the properties of the
elements are a function
of the atomic weight.
And, people were perplexed by the
fact that potassium is less massive
than argon. But no one would put
argon under sodium.
When Mendeleev's law is that you
arrange things by atomic mass.
Cobalt and nickel are reversed.
What to do? Here's Moseley. "We
are therefore led by experiment to
view that N, his capital N is what
we call proton number,
is the same as the number of the
place occupied by the element in the
periodic system."
"This atomic number,
he's coining the term.
"This atomic number is then for
hydrogen one, for helium two,
for lithium three, for calcium 20,
for zinc 30, etc. We can
confidently predict that in a few
cases in which the order of the
atomic weights A clashes with the
atomic order of the periodic system,
the chemical properties are governed
by N, while A itself,
probably a complicated function of N.
This is brilliant.
This is a graduate student in 1913
correcting Mendeleev.
So, what are the implications?
What are the implications? So,
this proton number, we're not going
to give it its due.
We are going to call it Z,
the atomic number. This is the
Social Security number of every atom,
the atomic number.
So, what's the significance of this
paper?
First of all, corrected Mendeleev,
not to say that Mendeleev was bad.
Mendeleev was brilliant in what he
did. But there were a few things
that Mendeleev couldn't account for.
So, now we know in the post-Moseley
world, that periodicity,
that is, the periodic variation in
properties is not a function
of atomic mass.
It's no longer a function of atomic
mass as per Mendeleev,
but rather a function of the atomic
number. OK, and this now resolves
the problems with argon,
potassium; cobalt, nickel; tellurium,
iodine, these three were known.
These three were known. And,
Mendeleev kept saying go and measure
them again. The atomic
masses are wrong.
And, he was right in certain
instances. They did find a number
of incorrect values.
But these weren't among that group.
And lastly, a pair that they
wouldn't have known: uranium and
neptunium are in the wrong order.
All right, so you say, OK, well
that's cute. But let me show you
something else.
By understanding that the atomic
number is the critical factor in
determining where something belongs
in the periodic table,
he was able to place the lanthanides.
If you look on the periodic tables
from the early part of the 20th
century, they don't know where to
put the lanthanides.
They are trivalent, so they tend to
put them under aluminum,
maybe under scandium. But they
don't know what to do with them.
So, with this, he was able to place
the lanthanides,
and more importantly,
he was able to predict that there
are 14 of them.
There are 14 in all.
Now, how do you do that?
It's really simple. Lanthanum was
discovered in 1839.
Lanthanum was discovered in 1839.
It has an atomic mass of 138.91,
and there were various other
lanthanides that had the discovered.
And, I'm going to put in lutecium,
which had been discovered only
recently in 1907. And, its
atomic mass is 174.97.
So what? What can I learn from this
about how many elements lie between
lanthanum and lutecium?
It's anybody's guess. But,
with Moseley, Moseley comes along
and he says, this isn't the critical
figure. The critical figure is the
atomic number.
I'm going to tell you because we
can do the experiment.
And, we can determine that
lanthanum has an atomic mass of 57,
and lutecium has an atomic mass of
71. Now, I ask you, how
many elements are there?
How many elements are there to be
discovered? With the atomic number,
everything is resolved. In fact,
once you know that the atomic number
of uranium is 92,
you can say with surety that there
are 92 naturally occurring elements
up to uranium.
They couldn't do this before
Moseley. And,
he kept going. He didn't stop with
this. Who else was in town
in 1913 in Manchester?
Niels Bohr. So,
Moseley looks at these data,
and he says, I wonder if I can fit
these data to a line?
So, he said, well, Bohr is in the
building. I'll go talk to Bohr.
And he says, why don't I use a
Rydberg-like equation?
And this is what he writes.
The nu bar varies with the square
of the proton number in the
following manner: R,
the Rydberg constant,
one over N final minus one over N
initial, each of them squared,
times Z squared.
But he knew those lines don't all go
through the origin.
They don't go through the origin.
So, it's Z minus some nonzero
constant squared.
So, wave number goes as the square
of the proton number,
but there's a little bit of an
offset. And this is called
Moseley's law.
This is Moseley's law.
So, it's a Rydberg type equation.
It's essentially a Bohr adaptation
for the x-ray spectra that he had
measured. And so,
for example, you can have a
Lyman-like series.
The Lyman-like series would be two
to one, right,
N equals two down to N equals one?
So that means, that's all of the K
alpha. So, the wave number of any K
alpha line is equal to,
if I plug in one over two squared
minus one over one squared,
this will come out to give me three
quarters times the Rydberg constant
times Z minus, pardon
me, sigma squared.
Well, he keeps going.
Let's see what he does.
He goes through, and he rewrote the
thing in a slightly different form.
But ultimately, if you read the
highlighted passage here,
hence the frequency nu varies as N
minus K squared,
and N for calcium is really 20,
then K equals one.
He solves for this thing,
solves for it. And look at this
little sort of very delicate,
extremely important statement.
But, very typical British
understatement: "there's good reason
to believe that the x-ray spectra
with which we are now dealing come
from the innermost ring of
electrons" because he knows
he's way down inside.
So, sigma equals one,
in this case, for K alpha.
And, there is a Balmer like series.
This is to x-ray what Balmer was to
hydrogen. And that would be lines
three to two. And,
so that would be by definition the L
alpha lines. And that would be one
over three squared minus one over
two squared, which gives you 536
times R times Z minus sigma squared.
And, it turns out that sigma equals
7.4 for L alpha series.
So, this is really good.
Now, let's go into the physics.
Let's try to understand, what is
this sigma? Where does it come from?
So, for that, let's look
at this little cartoon.
Here's my K shell.
This is K shell. Here's the L
shell. Here's the M shell.
Now, K shell, I've got maximum.
I've got two electrons max, filled.
OK, L shell I've got eight
electrons max.
And, out here I've got 18 electrons
max. Let's look at,
first of all, sigma equals one.
That involves transitions from L
down to K.
So, for transitions from L down to K,
normally I've got two electrons in
the N equals one shell.
If I'm going to have cascade,
one of these is missing. There's a
vacancy down here.
So let's go up here.
I've got one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven, eight.
Now the eight of these electrons
are feeling the positive attraction
of the nucleus mediated by the
presence of the one electron.
So, you see plus Z minus one.
So, we say that the attractive force
of nucleus is mediated.
Or, we say the electron screens the
attractive force of the nucleus.
So, the outer electrons are going to
fall down, don't get the full brunt
of the positive force of the nucleus.
And, there's only one electron here.
So, instead of Z,
it's Z minus one. It makes sense.
It makes sense. And, how about,
let's do the next one.
The next one would be from three to
two. So, out here,
I've got electrons. If they are
going to go from three to two,
I need at least one vacancy. I
could have a vacancy here.
So, there's maybe, instead of eight
electrons there is seven.
Here, there's either one or two
electrons. Suppose there's two here
and there's seven here.
That's nine. Suppose it is only
one here. Well,
one plus seven is eight.
But, maybe I've blown both of these
out. Maybe I've blown more than one
of these out so,
you put it all together,
and it turns out that the number has
to be somewhere on the order of what?
Eight, seven,
something like that?
And, sure enough, the number is 7.
.
So, there is a physical basis for
the screening factor.
Sigma is termed the screening
factor. The screening factor
defines a Z effective,
not the Z. There's a Z effective.
It's what's mediated. And to show
you, just to get a sense of how
powerful Moseley was,
here's the thing. I told you that
I've had it drilled into my head
that the lambda of copper K alpha is
1.5418 angstroms.
There's not many things I know of
five significant figures.
I know my Social Security number to
nine significant figures.
But I know this one to five
significant figures.
And, if you use Moseley's law,
lambda of copper K alpha for Moseley
is 1.546 angstroms.
And, the delta here is 0.
%, one third of one percent.
There's no question this man should
have won the Nobel Prize.
He should have won it right away.
But he didn't. Mosley was very
politically active.
And, he decided when World War I
broke out to enlist in the British
military. And,
Rutherford was furious.
Rutherford called the Secretary of
War and tried to get Moseley a desk
job and keep him in London.
And, Moseley refused.
So, he ended up in the military,
and one of the major battles of
World War I was the Battle of Suvla
Bay, which was part of the Gallipoli
campaign, which was managed by none
other than Winston Churchill.
This cost Churchill his political
capital. It took him years to
recover from the debacle of the
Battle of Gallipoli.
The Battle of Suvla Bay took a
quarter of a million lives on the
Allied side, and about a third of
the million lives on the Turkish
side, over half a million people
killed in that campaign.
And, on August 8,
1915, at the age of 27,
Moseley was killed in action.
And, they don't give the Nobel
Prize posthumously.
So, no Nobel for this,
one of the most brilliant pieces of
work in those early days of the 20th
century. Bohr said that World War I,
he called World War I a horrible
spectacle inflicting great
losses on humanity.
But the number one loss to the world
was Henry Gwyn Jeffreys Moseley.
So, that's why you won't see
Moseley's name among the physics
Nobelists. Well,
this is brilliant work.
Is there any data? What's the data?
Well, what should this look like?
If we take this set of lines and we
make a spectrum,
the spectrum will be intensity,
right, intensity versus some energy
coordinate.
OK, so we should have something that
looks like this: K alpha,
K beta, and then over here,
L alpha, L beta. That's what it
should look like.
And, so just to be clear,
we have an emission spectrum that is
quantized. It's quantized because
the energy levels are quantized.
So, we have a quantized emission
spectrum. That's what we should
expect to find.
It's a function of the atomic
number of the specimen.
And, so we say that this spectrum is
characteristic of the target,
or of the anode. And, I told you
last day, if I walked into a room
and I saw an x-ray spectrum,
and I saw that this was 1.54 Å,
I go its copper because as Z changes,
so does the element.
In fact, look at how sensitive this
technique is.
It's additive.
Look down here at brass.
Brass is an alloy of copper and
zinc. So, there's the copper lines.
And in brass, you see the copper
lines, and you see the zinc lines.
So, by this technique, I could give
you an alloy consisting of three
elements. And,
you could see from where those lines
are what the elements must be that
are present in the alloy.
And, the relative intensity of the
lines must be related to the
relative concentrations of this
constituents that are present.
This is so important.
It's amazing. All right,
so let's look at the data. Here's
the data. This is data from
molybdenum. Now,
remember, this is what we are
expecting, and this is what we've
got. So, it's there's something
else going on here.
It looks as though what we have is
a combination of,
it looks like we've got a
combination of this plus this.
So, this here is our characteristic
spectrum. It's as though our
characteristic spectrum is imposed
upon something else.
And this something else is
continuous, right?
There's no break in this curve.
So, this is a continuous spectrum.
This is a continuous spectrum.
There are various ways of
describing the shape.
It's certainly asymmetric.
But since we're in New England,
we call this whale shaped. It's a
whale shaped. And,
it's got a very steep,
it's got a vertical rise here.
I want you to note the shape. It's
not just arbitrarily drawn.
It's a steep vertical rise,
and then an asymptotic tail, and of
course a maximum skewed
asymmetrically.
So it's not quantized.
And, furthermore, if you look at
this figure carefully,
you'll see that there is a family of
these. There is a family of these,
and they are enveloping one another.
They envelop one another as shown
here so that as the plate voltage
increases, the height increases and
the minimum wavelength decreases.
So, if this is wavelength
increasing from left to right,
this means that energy is increasing
from right to left,
which makes sense. As you go to
higher plate voltage, you
go to higher energies.
But, what's going on here?
What's the physics of the spectrum?
Oh, by the way, and the highest one,
you see the K alpha,
K beta designation? If you didn't
know what they were,
you just took the value of K alpha,
it looks like it's around, oh, about
three quarters of an angstrom by my
eyeballing it.
It looks like it's about three
quarters of an angstrom.
And, if you take the calculation of
Moseley's Law for lambda
of molybdenum K alpha.
You know that molybdenum is Z equals
42 for Moly. Z equals 42; plug them
in and you get 0.
2 Å. So, that seems to be OK.
So, in other words, Moseley is
predicting the peaks.
And, the peak, by the way,
is I'm drawing a straight line like
this. But in reality,
these peaks have some finite width
because real materials are not
perfect. And so,
there's going to be some variation
in the spacing and the energies.
OK, so what's going on here?
How can we explain this? What's
the underlying physics here?
Well, let's take a look. Here's a
body centered cubic crystal,
as is molybdenum. So, let's say the
plane of the table is the anode.
And, the electrons are zooming in
from the cathode in the ceiling.
So, the electrons are coming down.
They're coming down, and smashing
into this. And,
something's going on that causes the
emission of x-rays
in all directions.
And, we've just seen,
it's OK, you've seen in the central
board, there, what those energies
should be, the discrete energies.
But let's see what else is going on.
Let's zoom in at the free surface
of the molybdenum.
Here's body centered cubic.
And, the electrons are coming in.
Let's say electrons coming in from
the top, and electrons charge
negatively. And,
we know that this is net neutral.
But, there is an electron cloud.
And so, we've seen Born repulsion in
the past. We're going to see it
again. The mutual repulsion of the
electrons in the molybdenum atom
with the incident electron that's
just arrived long distance from the
cathode is going to cause some
repulsion. And it's going to be a
deflection. Another electron might
come in a little closer.
If it comes in closer, it might be
deflected more.
Now, when a charged particle
changes direction,
you know, any particle,
forget charged particle,
a change in speed or a change in
direction represents
an acceleration.
But, when a charged particle
accelerates, that causes emission of
radiation. So,
every one of these changes in
direction, change of direction we
term acceleration.
That's point one. And,
point two, charge accelerating
produces radiation because
it's an energy change.
So, what kind of radiation?
Every one of these comes off.
They give off a photon. And,
different deflections mean different
energy differences.
Modest deflections,
modest difference, intense
deflection, intense difference.
You might even get one that comes in
sort of a la Rutherford that comes
in and gets turned around.
So, what do we see? That could
explain what's going on here,
where we have at the one extreme,
this is very low. This is a high
wavelength, low energy.
So, this is low energy; this is low
angle deflection.
And, this is the most common.
This is the most common angle.
And, over here is very high angle,
and there aren't many of them. And
we can't predict what this line is.
There's no way we can calculate
that curve except for one point on
it. And, that's the remote
possibility that an electron comes
in dead-on, stops,
is captured by the molybdenum atom,
and gives up all of its kinetic
energy and converts it
to photon energy.
And, that one we can calculate,
for that one we know that if we take
the energy of the incident electron,
the total energy. Total kinetic
energy is equal to what?
The product of the charge on the
electron times the plate voltage.
The charge on the electron is the
elementary charge,
and convert that into the energy of
the emitted photon,
which is equal to hc over lambda.
If we do that,
we can invert this and get the value
for this point here,
which is lambda of the shortest
wavelength, which is the wavelength
represented by the conversion of the
total kinetic energy of the incident
electron, lambda of the shortest
wavelength, then, will equal
hc over e times V.
And, if you plug in Planck's
constant, speed of light,
elementary charge, you end up with
12,400 over plate voltage in
angstroms. You know I am not fond
of the nanometer.
I insist on using the angstrom in
defiance of Systeme International.
So, it's 12,400 divided by plate
voltage. So, you can see that if
you have on the order of 10,
00 volts, 10,000 V will give you a
shortest wavelength of 1.
4 angstroms, smack dab in the middle
of the x region of the spectrum.
And that's what you're seeing up
here. There is another term for
this phenomenon of changing
directions. And it comes from the
idea that we are decelerating the
incident electrons,
decelerating not by changing
velocity, but by changing direction.
And, it's the German term
Bremsstrahlung.
Brems means to brake as in putting
on the brakes of your car.
Brems means to brake, and strahl is
the word for ray.
Strahl means ray.
So, this literally means braking
radiation. It's the radiation from
the braking of the incident
electrons, braking radiation.
So, the bremsstrahlung plus the
characteristic spectrum give us what
we see in the figure up here.
Last topic I want to cover is
something on instrumentation and
safety. A number of you approached
me after the last lecture and asked,
with incredulity, how could these
people work with these generators
exposed to x-rays?
These were clear glass tubes
emanating in all directions x-rays.
Well, the answer is it was unsafe,
and many of them died as a result of
the radiation exposure because they
didn't know at the time what was
going on. So,
I want to show you several things
that have been done in order to make
things a little bit safer,
and also to be more efficient.
And, what I'm going to show you is
the design by Coolidge in 1913.
And Coolidge made the following
improvements. And,
I think I've got a cartoon up here.
This is taken from one of your
readings out of the supplement.
This is out of the Stout and Jensen
book. So, this is figure 1.
. What I did is I turned it on its
side so it would look like all of
our gas tubes.
Every gas tube I've ever drawn for
you has the anode on the right.
So, just to orient it I lay it on
its side. And so,
the anode is on the right.
The cathode is on the left.
And now, what I want to do is
highlight what the improvements have
been. So, the first thing that
Coolidge did is he used a
bona fide vacuum tube.
He got the gas pressure way,
way down. And, this did two things.
First of all, there's no glow in
the visible. And secondly,
it's a much higher efficiency
because when you have glow,
what it means is that some of those
electrons leaving the cathode are
not getting to the anode.
They are colliding with gas
molecules and consuming their energy.
So, by the time they get to the
anode, they don't have enough punch
to kick out inner shell electrons.
So, the vacuum tube is an
improvement. The second thing is
hot cathode. What happens with a
hot cathode? You know,
you have to rip the electrons out of
the cathode. And the electrons are
bound. So, if you raise the
temperature of the cathode,
the thermal energy then weakens the
bonds. And so,
it takes less Coulombic force to rip
the electrons out.
Now, how's he going to heat the
cathode? Let's think about this.
You can't use a torch because
you've got a vacuum inside.
So, a torch won't work in a vacuum.
So, I wonder, maybe if I passed a
current, and sure enough,
what he does is he's got a second
power supply. You see,
here's the anode over here.
Here's the cathode, and there's the
30,000, 40,000 volts between the
cathode and the anode.
And, the electrons boil off here
and zoom from left to right.
And, he's got a second little
circuit here. You can put more than
one electrical signal through an
item. So, let's put a second
circuit through here.
And, this circuit is a little
heater circuit.
And, all it does is it makes this
cathode filament through joule
heating, raise its temperature.
And that makes the electrons less
tightly bound,
so it's easier to boil them off.
So, the hot cathode, by raising
temperature, reduces binding of the
electrons. And,
you're trying to get rid of them.
The third thing he did was water
cooling.
You've got all of these electrons.
They've zoomed across at an
acceleration voltage of 30,
40, 50,000 volts. They're crash,
crash, crash, crash, hitting that
copper or molybdenum anode.
Where is that kinetic energy going?
Some of it's going into light, and
some of it's going into heat.
And, the temperature of the anode
is rising to the point where you
could melt this.
So, what Coolidge did is he put the
anode on a hearth, and
the hearth is copper..
And underneath,
there's water running through copper
tubing. So, by water cooling,
he's able to keep the anode cool,
so, dissipate heat, and the second
thing, remember,
Roentgen used pulse power.
It was eight times a second: bam,
bam, bam, bam. If you've got water
cooling, now you can go to
continuous power,
dissipated heat, and allowed for
continuous current flow.
If you've got continuous current,
that means you've got continuous
x-ray emission.
You don't want an x-ray flashbulb.
You want an x-ray beam. And, the
last thing he did is probably the
most important thing is he put lead
shielding, which I've indicated in
yellow, he put lead shielding and
beryllium windows.
Beryllium windows for efficiency,
and lead shielding for safety.
OK, now let's think about it.
Let's think about why we would
choose these. Why would you choose
lead for the shielding and beryllium
for the window?
For that, I decided,
why don't we go back to our friend
the periodic table?
Look at where beryllium and lead
lie on the periodic table.
Beryllium is the lightest practical
element. Hydrogen and helium are
gases, and lithium as a metal is
unstable in moist air.
Beryllium is the first metal that
can be used sensibly in our
atmosphere. And,
look at lead. Lead is down here.
And remember, it's 1913 so forget
about the actinides.
So, you've got bismuth,
polonium, and astatine. So,
lead is effectively the heaviest
practical element.
Why would you choose this?
Why would you choose lead as your
shielding? What do we know about
the energy levels in lead?
First of all, there's lots of them
because you have not
only K, L, M, and N.
You've got n. You keep going,
oh. So, you've got plenty of levels.
And, the levels are very closely
spaced. So, if you've got lots of
energy levels,
and they're closely spaced,
then that means when an x-ray comes
in, you'll have excitation and
cascading down into much,
much longer wavelengths. So,
because of the extra energy levels,
this causes the lead to act as a
frequency shifter.
So, it moves you out of the x region.
You still get radiation,
but it's not so toxic. I mean,
you have conservation of energy here.
But, I mean, you don't have things
coming at you into x region of the
spectrum. So,
if there were a shortage of lead,
or, let's say, for the man or woman
who has everything,
when he or she goes to the dentist,
what would be a really chi-chi
material to make the vest out of?
Mercury is a liquid at room
temperature, bad choice.
Thallium: toxic. How about gold?
How about a vest made of gold? It
would work. That would be a classy
vest. Now, how about up here?
Beryllium window: beryllium is the
inverse. Beryllium has very few
energy levels and they are far apart.
So that we don't want the x-rays
absorbed as they are
going to the window.
So, if you had a window that wasn't
crystalline beryllium,
you run the risk of losing some of
your x-rays. So,
your efficiency goes down.
So, you choose a low z element for
the window, and the high z element
for the shielding for those reasons.
It all goes back to the internal
structure energy levels.
OK, well, let's take a look at
another use of x-rays,
x-rays in art.
This painting,
anybody recognize this one?
The Angelus by Jean Francois Millet
painted in 1857-1859 on commission
for an insurance company in Boston.
Millet was very popular with Boston
Brahmins because he painted rural
life in 19th century France.
This painting was commissioned and
hung here in Boston.
It's now at the Musee d'Orsay.
Salvador Dali had to paint this as
part of his art education.
He hated this painting, and in 1963,
it was hanging in the Louvre.
And he had the painting x-rayed.
He said there's something spooky
about this painting.
Well, Dali had such authority that
he could ask for the x-ray,
and they x-rayed it. And they
discovered that,
indeed, the painting had been
painted over. It's
not an art forgery.
It turns out that this zone down
here, the little basket of potatoes
was not the basket of potatoes in
the original painting.
The original painting depicted the
casket of a baby.
This is showing the poverty,
the futility, of peasant life in
France. And, these people are so
poor that they just lost their baby.
Now, you can imagine that this
painting comes to Boston.
They unveil it, and they say,
my God, we can't hang this in the
lobby of an insurance company.
So, my theory is that they sent it
back and Millet painted it over,
put a basket of potatoes. But,
their heads are not bowed in the
form of saying a prayer thanking God
for this miserable bounty of
potatoes. It doesn't make sense.
So, x-rays figured out what was
going on. So then,
Dali got a chance to paint.
And this is his revenge. This is
his painting in 1935.
This is Dali, and this is his
father. You notice in this case,
the man is taller than the woman.
Here, the woman is taller than the
man. There's all kinds of Freudian
stuff going on with where he's got
his hat placed,
but I don't have enough time to go
into that. So,
you can see. While we're talking
about Dali, here's the
hallucinogenic toreador.
And, I want to show you this
because it hearkens back to crystal
structures. He went out one day in
Manhattan to buy some Venus pencils.
They're pencils, but the Venus was
the manufacturer.
See, I have the Venus de Milo on
the pencil box.
So, you see a bunch of Venuses
facing forward,
and some facing back.
Can you see the breast here is the
nose of the toreador?
Here's it's mouth; does that help?
OK, those are the gadflies of St.
Narciso, which is I think the patron
saint of Catalonia.
You see, here's his cape,
and there's the bull. And,
you can see symmetry planes here.
OK, there's the head of the thing,
OK. There's the bull, yeah, yeah.
OK, now look, here's the symmetry.
See, these Venuses are forward.
These Venuses are facing backward.
What else do we have?
I don't know why it's doing this.
OK, now, there's the bull. What's
the crystal structure?
See, this is the life force leaving
the bull. What's the crystal
structure? If you ignore color it's
simple cubic. You can even see
symmetry here.
You see the shadow of the fly?
You see these two atoms here, these
two atoms here?
There's even something.
You see the shadow of the Venus
actually looks a little bit like,
come on, come on, come on.
It looks a little bit like this.
He really hated this. OK, we're
going to show you one more and go
through this. Ah,
this is his tribute to Watson and
Crick. Over here,
you have the DNA double helix,
and what he's portraying here is
that now that we have the capacity
to understand how life is encoded,
replication, and so on, ironically,
humanity hasn't figured out how to
stop killing itself.
And so, he has this group of people
all arranged in cubic arrays with
muskets pointing at one another.
Again, crystallography, you could
say actually this is simple cubic,
but if you put somebody inside, it
would be body centered cubic.
[LAUGHTER] On the last thing,
lithium, why is 7-Up called 7-Up?
When it first came out it was
called lithiated lemon-lime soda.
It contained lithium citrate in
large quantities.
It was supposed to make you happy.
It was an anti-depressant. And, it
turns out that some people have a
sodium deficiency.
Lithium's a smaller ion.
If you're already sodium deficient,
lithium gets in there, displaces a
sodium; you die.
[LAUGHTER] So, after some tens of
people died, they took the lithium
out around 1950.
So, you don't have lithium in your
7-Up today. I'll see you on Friday.